[Music]
okay i mean fm 2800
all right
let's play all open
non-seasonal thank you for the prime
it's weird how many people play this
pretty bad line with d6
yeah knight 85 now
i think the move is 93
or is it knight bd2 i don't remember i
think it's knight a3
this is potentially a threat
thank you the modern penguin
oh yeah
can you headboard sounds yes
[Music]
done
all right so he's sacking upon we're
definitely gonna
take that
[Music]
okay now i can go
c4 i can go a board i can just go back
to a3
nothing wrong with that
yeah he wants sort of bank of gambits i
don't think black has enough
compensation here
generally fight has that c4 square
it's like 16-30 i mean it's fine
not my best match with magnus
i wish we could play more i mean
i i was getting better as the match went
on
seth
yeah there's just no competing with them
way too strong
yeah
there's just no
okay c8 we can hit him with bishop g5
go ahead
i might not answer it but you can ask
now now i'm intrigued what's
how is magnus so strong and below
because he's magnus
yeah magnus isn't great for him you can
just tell he's very sharp these days
yeah i'm not gonna take that pawn i
could maybe take it but he goes g5 and
he traps my bishop so
yeah how is why is the world champion
good
okay so
he's gonna go here and there
i'm not beginning to not like this okay
so 93 i could
let me think i could meet knight d3 with
b4 i need to prepare that which means i
need to move this rook away
we can move it to d1 and mislead him
thank you dr j bird
i mean you have to look at amazon for
these types of things
yeah this guy's good
knight takes
yeah kind of a lot of five
what's the oh you can repeat the
question
would you go to riga or the situation or
cancel it if you were on the list i
would i mean if i was planning to play i
would probably play that's not a
controversial question i mean it's a
legitimate
i would i would play
um if i was
planning to go
but it's a personal choice at this point
[Music]
okay this is completely winning
just gotta the only thing we should
avoid is some rook b1 bull
crap
okay why am i struggling this i guess we
can take
check him
get him with knight f7
so there's just one threat if i defend
against it i'm
chill
yeah we're chilling here
oh except one thing
uh oh he has got
that doesn't work okay check him and
take
if he takes it i take
b7 made as a threat
resigns
okay let's play dragon
i mean
i'm sure that there are some behind the
you know i i'm sure that in getting the
tournament approved there are some
backdoor deals but
i mean it is what it is
what's up what's up
i think d4 bishop's i don't think i
there was no theory here
i mean that's how things are done
sometimes
i think people like ray
uh determined that they just don't have
that many chances to to qualify to win
and it's also a pretty
you know traveling to latvia is
a hassle so
hey
okay let's go a5 a4
it goes a4 wow okay
that is bold
i'm gonna go here
i don't i don't know if hess is still
going actually i think he might not be
one of the things is that if you're
going
and you want to also have oh crap i
blended the spawn but not a tragedy it's
okay and pretend it's a sack
i i actually don't know you should ask
hess on his stream i i
i just knew that he was hesitating
completely understandable
yeah but i'm in trouble this insane move
queen c5 i mean
i shouldn't give him to give that one
away
let's go back
man maybe i had
maybe this is a threat
dude he's the world champion and i'm not
i mean there's no
secret
ingredient i mean
he's just good
it's just
everything yeah i mean king h7 to defend
against that okay but now
this one i'm not too scared of
okay i could go for a better end game i
think i'm gonna do that
slightly better end game maybe
you know
maybe i should go h5 so i can have
bishop h6 later when i need it i don't
know if this is the right approach but
yeah of course i think in 30 second i
would be the favorite of magnus but
we're not playing 30 seconds
i should have gone bishop h60 now he's
going to go f4
very sloppy i mean it's still i'm much
better e4 and d3 is coming
oh god
what's your bullet rating 31 okay i mean
i'm potentially
i kind of want to play blitz to be
honest
i don't know if i want to play more
bullet
do you want to play blitz or do you are
you pretty intent on let me play one
more with this guy and then and then
i'll decide
i don't know if you guys want to see
bullet with brandon or not
boring
[Music]
no no no hyperbola that's for sure
yeah this is all theory
dipiendo
i don't know who you're referring to
oh i love knight f4
this is a bad opening thank you empire
lofty he doesn't do it
oh i see why you didn't do it
hmm
thank you
yeah i guess it's acceptable to castle
here
i mean i know ubaru is i played him but
he's a gm and this guy's an fm
i'm also kind of getting crushed here
okay i thought i have f3 here but it's
pretty tenuous
yes i have magnus's cell phone number
and his whatsapp and his skype
i can ping him any second of the day
yeah also his bank account that's kind
of goes without saying that's that part
is obvious
i mean i think his mother's maiden name
is probably readily available ingrid
ingrid ingridsen i don't know
yeah we spoke on stream before therefore
we're best friends
i mean i keep managing to get myself in
trouble against this guy
okay he wants to give this pawn and then
wait what if i take him go bishop g3
goes queen c7
yeah that might be dangerous can you one
hard to say but i don't particularly
like the idea of okay i can try to
i can try to um mix things up with c4 i
need to flee a little bit faster here
v5 maybe is dangerous
i'll be fine i have some 93 business if
he takes on d4 there i can take and play
knight f5 check
92.
see he wants some shenanigans let's
start with d5 and make him think
okay
i definitely don't believe this but
probably
uh-huh i see what he wants he wants her
kj rook h1 and then queen sack
yes understood
okay what if i take this way
if i take it goes there
there there
he's starting rook h3
oh my gosh
okay let's go four
yeah this has gone south for him i think
do
okay i just have to dodge one last set
of bullets here
and we're gonna dodge them by going to
an end game
okay wait so i'm gonna go there
i missed f6 it's okay oh bishop c6 is
winning
yeah nice that was a nice game
okay let's play an alakan let's see what
he knows
h3
i guess we can go bishop f5
i'm not familiar with this at all
i can just go back to c8 i basically
claim that i've induced a weakness
i think this is an interesting approach
yet but here i go like
before he wants to go like this
yeah he's gonna force my knight to asic
to me it's not so good
maybe not in classical but in blitz
anything goes
i mean this is not impressive though
what's up peter's thumb there
yeah we'll probably have one or two dj
streams this week
sorry there's a
smokey
i'm pretty sure it's i will not perish
in a fire tonight
oh rook
yeah that's the whole idea
nah nah i i played one tournament and
then that's it i decided it wasn't chess
isn't for me and
it was the last one
i mean it's too stressful i don't really
like oh my god like it's
way too stressful
am i trolling no i mean i
okay i made that video on over the board
tournaments
it was mostly meant for me i mean i i've
never played over the board before and
probably never will again
thank you for the hundred bits
okay the jokes aside i'm getting
outplayed in this game
probably deservingly cell
yeah i mean uh some time stream but
whatever
but it's going to be typical in a
northeast
all right now i can go here wait a
minute i can go there there there
[Music]
there there
or i can go rook d3 but that looks more
fishy i don't get what he wants against
knight d3
yeah he had no
intention against that
okay maybe he has knight takes b7 but
then i just moved my rook and he's
forked
in both senses of the word
i guess he wants to go back to c5 it's a
nice idea
oh oh shoot he takes this way
i
keep missing
small details
okay we have to keep our rooks active so
right now there's no threats let's bring
our king a little bit closer
gotta make sure we have luft and the
king positioning is good
it's vishy good in chess anymore
that's what a dumb question of course he
sucks i mean when you hit 50 years old i
mean you just
ah he sucks
he sees ass
yeah he forgot he forgot how to play
basically
what the hell am i doing
i'm trying to
create some sort of mating net against
him
but in doing so i'm giving all my pawns
away
this is not good
probably lost
no 98 oh i missed 19.
okay
let's go
oops and i'm else of c3 nice good start
to the second game all right to the next
game whatever okay we can transpose in
tutorial but okay
okay that was close too close for
comfort
well played by my opponent but okay now
i think the point is yeah if you're 666
i'll be take care
he knows the line if he takes to the
bishop there's this fork on e3
now min min is like an expert in these
types of positions i'm not
okay
i mean watching a movie and analyzing it
is not the worst assignment so not
really
okay so again i'm getting outplayed
h5
could it maybe be that other strong
people have played in the world of the
championship and
it's not that easy to win it
it could be a theory i don't know if it
holds any water
i'm getting crushed
no but i mean i'm getting i'm having fun
there's this many like questions like
this i have no choice
okay now i have to pull out a draw
yeah i blundered queen e4 it's lost
yeah i forgot he has repeated one
yeah that was a terrible terrible game
i should just go e4 i don't know what
i'm doing
stupid experiments in the opening
oh my god i'm out of my mind i forgot
that one exists
it takes that surprising before i think
was just winning
i'm sure this is also completely winning
but
maybe at least there's some counter play
before queen c7 it's not entirely clear
d1 queen b7
or maybe i have this one
[Music]
let's get this
okay not terrible i mean i've got
pressure on this one
i guess i could take
okay takes he takes it queen b1 is good
i think we can do this and then we can
move the knight away because the rook is
protected
yeah yeah this is good
now i have to find a way to
get him in some sort of a net
okay let's just go back to d6 play more
conservatively here
now he's gonna lose the pawn
okay i just gotta be very careful of
bishop h6 it's the only thing
i can avoid getting checkmated i'm in
good shape
maybe i failed
okay at least i can go here
oh no bishop g7 oh my gosh you managed
to fill out a draw incredible
just amazing
i'm i'm not good i'm gonna go for the
flag though
i don't think he's gonna make it
okay
it's a gutsy move there but it pays off
oh yeah that was just
dirty let's try again
let's just go e4
yeah i should not have allowed that
queen e2 is very strong here
i don't remember anything else here i
think i'm supposed to castle
it was a nice nice flagging try
of course
all right thank you for this four months
okay this is very suspicious
i mean i personally don't think it's
disrespectful to win i mean i don't even
understand what it means for
a win to be disrespectful
so
yeah no of course
i think there can be some egregious
flagging but
that wasn't really
i wouldn't put that in that category
yeah i think
i don't really know what to compare it
to i think
i was thinking of possible analogies to
make
to show people that it's pretty normal
to
win based on the clock clack clock but
it it's hard to come up with an analog
in another sport
maybe about the shot clock in basketball
but it's not the same
i think one way to think about it is to
ask yourself why do you like blitz in
the first place why is blitz fun
and i think the answer to that is
well presumably you enjoy blitz because
the time constraint forces the players
to play fast it's the only difference it
will be inconsistent to suddenly then
say oh
i like blitz because of the time because
of the
time limit but
i don't like it when players win the
game because of the clock that just
sounds very inconsistent to me
all right let's take it
takes it the queen i didn't expect that
i thought he would take with the king
yeah i don't know what's going on
some [ __ ]
very sloppy sloppy play by me
this is not exactly what i wanted
although i am up let's say a pawn
okay so if he takes it i think i go king
g2 or maybe even king h2
wait what
that came out of left field wait what if
i just i don't get it oh he's got queen
f5 what an insane idea
okay i probably just need to
something of this sort then he's oh my
god then he's got queen
it's a queen h5 and
not good
yeah i was hoping you would blunder just
like that now i take i chop the legs off
the attack and
throw in another check for good measure
and then take the night
force the rook back
let's bring all the
toys back to the nursery party and go
rookie one
now our goal is to trade works let's go
here
ah he's got queen a8 it's still not over
oh i'd also
i thought of something
which is that i think in this case
there's a type of argument that i would
call the actual argument which is
basically for anything for any bad
behavior
you could say
well i don't think that
if you don't want to to
face that behavior then you don't have
to do the thing in the first place
but in this case i think it it carries
some weight because you actually can
only play three plus one there's plenty
of people willing to play with an
increment
so it is actually is possible to
avoid getting flags
if you so
desire i think a lot of people forget
about that for some reason
okay this is actually a very tricky line
against the fantasy nobody knows how to
play against it
no it's not it's not bad i mean
right you can't stand the heat get out
of the kitchen
this guy is very very sharp he sees
all these little tactical tricks that
people generally miss in blitz
what's up barbara
okay we're going to try to induce b3
and this guy's legit legit good
oh lag no i cried about lag too i don't
know anybody who doesn't cry about lag
because lag is
lack compensation to not be tilted a lot
of compensation you have to be like a
buddhist
monk
so
okay let's keep mounting the pressure on
his queen side the spawn is weak we can
try to move
all
right maybe we can throw in age a4 yeah
try to try to jam and guess the c4
square
[Music]
i think maybe we can go like this
obviously
it's a blunder c4 yeah
first of all
[ __ ] fish german what are you talking
about
i don't really have an impression of any
german grandmasters
you can sort of do some more generic
type but
don't really know anybody who sounds
like this
okay let's throw in a b just to get some
block off his time
and it takes
whoa
my man
not going i don't think this is going to
work
actually it's not so simple to defend
against
okay this is a potential threat once he
unfins himself so let's go rookie six
take c4 i mean i feel like i'm
collecting so much material here and
let's just go roxy to throw him into the
abyss
bishop f1
nice this is winning excellent
okay let's try to
get over 3050 this game thank you shaky
warrior
okay how are we gonna play this let's
play a nerocon
oh man he knows that too e5 is the best
move i mean it's like
this guy is crazy
if you know what to do against queen f3
it's like
come on
okay i'm not sure bishop d6 is correct
yeah those puzzles are the most tilting
when you feel like every move wins and
you don't understand what the
distinction is
okay we have to go h3 to stop fisher g4
this is important in this line
generally black goes v5 at some point
before 94
95 white is slightly better i think
we can go like g4 to try to dissolate
him from going five but i think it's
more important to develop here
there should be seven yeah maybe i
should have taken it first yeah yeah i
definitely should have taken that fish i
don't know i didn't
now i'm gonna walk right into this
let's try to gear up for it
and then i want to reroute the knight to
f3 potentially
clean my kit trap there so
looks like i need to be a little bit
more careful let's go knight g3 maybe
oh god here we go again with frap
i think now knight f3 is better movement
than it was before that's okay i really
don't know
yeah it is
it's groundhog day
okay i need to be very very careful here
i might have already blundered
because he has simply juice i mean why
did i not do anything about that
i didn't even stop to consider his
threats i just played like an idiot here
okay if i move my knight he goes g6
that's the problem
and i'm going to end up with
unbelievable
yeah that's another loss
i don't know what he's waiting for
queen g6 i'll take it and go 95 i mean
still if i can suck
some time off this clock maybe it's
another super accurate move
maybe this
then he goes
on but then 28 maybe
i can try to scare him
okay you can't take my knight he gets
mated
i think bishop b7 is winning for black
which means i think he'll play it
then maybe queen d7 i don't know just
keep
bleeding some time off this clock
yeah queen takes c5 queen b7 knight c7
i'll play it for sure
knight c7 is easy i don't know what he's
thinking about
this guy is incredibly tilting
it probably has to go three
can probably maybe somehow but oh he
just goes here come on
this drops my queen
you know i allowed that
whoa
my mayan
goes there
takes check
and
where's the mate i
there's no mate
what to do let's do it to do oh do i
take it do i go like this maybe
just trying to bleed time off his clock
yeah let's just take and flag him oh god
now he's going to mate me
i'm not careful
god how did he do that
let's go h4 get the hell out of there
get out out out out out
oh my god
holy smokes
what a game
completely he was winning in one move i
mean
i think this is interesting i don't
really know how to play this line
this guy seems to know
every theoretical line in the book but
okay maybe i mixed mixed up two lines
yeah super intense game but we swindle
him in the end
f5 may be coming
magnus doesn't own it play magnus group
owns it
or i think has bought it i mean it's not
the same thing
there's a
there isn't a what
i think oh i see maya hello coach maya
thank you for the uh thank you for the
sub
yeah magnus has a lot to do
with the 13 months
thank you miss the master for the 14.
yeah now i still have nice position
maybe after knight f4 ideas somehow
okay this guy erasmus spain is playing
the 2600 i think
try to
geek guam
thank you
thank you jordan there we go let's go
jordan mains with a tier one thank you
get some subs going
oh
okay that's good
i i could maybe go knight d who i don't
really want to bother with the
calculations
okay how do we want to arrange our
pieces i think the queen comes back to
d6
and then maybe we can simply double on
the f file and
okay i'm gonna go a6 b5 also maybe like
that
one's queen a2 i guess
this gives me the opportunity to
thank you for the opportunity
now let's go back to these
[Music]
this is
thanks i mean i don't think my forum was
too bad at the tournament but i
appreciate it
okay so i think that's enough for this
guy
and i can play more but
maybe we can try to get rasmus
wow
on the other hand he's probably playing
this
super match i mean i guess i can
continue this guy
i forgot he plays the carl gun
okay let's play
takes an
95
this line i know
okay i'm sure he knows this as well
yeah he plays
the annoying one i think
acknowledge
me i see
i see how it is
toxic as usual
okay he goes g6
no i don't think he's gm strength i
think he's probably i am strength
i don't know if he actually wants to
take this or not
i mean
it's possible
i also really don't want to play g3
maybe 95
i'm gonna do a positional sack i'm gonna
go bishop i'm gonna invite him to take
okay he takes it instantly
and i'm gonna bank on long-term pressure
okay let's stop him from going c5 and if
i can stop him from going e5 i think i'm
in good shape
oh but now i have cb and i have this
passer
a little surprising to me maybe i should
have gone ap i don't know
because now i have a hard time
preventing everything
honest toxic is proper but close
okay now we can try to get the knight
over to c5
and then if i can get a4a5 and i think
i've got most of the bases covered here
yeah 1800 in a year is pretty impressive
okay knight c5 is
potentially incoming
okay now we just have to deal with
i don't see a reason not to take this
bishop is good but
okay also there are no threats so maybe
i should just be patient
something like rookie two makes some
sense
i could also take and go knight c5a4 if
i know this looks good
it goes ef he wants to open the e file
that makes
a certain degree of sense
now he's going to go f4
maybe i shouldn't have allowed this
counterplay
i'm gonna withhold a6 for now i'm gonna
rush it
it goes rookie then i'm gonna go a6 for
sure
okay he takes it i thought it would take
with the queen just to get control of
the e file
i think now the time is probably right
for a6
okay let's throw an h3
e5 maybe was
more direct i don't know
to be very careful about like some sort
of well-timed f3
i'm gonna take my chances with that move
because if f3 i have queen b7 forcing
the queen trade and i think in the end
game
should be winning
oh he goes there
okay i have take some takes also
or i could
yeah i think i'm just gonna play it safe
here so you can take
all right
let's go knight f6 let's go with the
nimzo sicilian
oh very calm g
three okay let's go g6
that was a really nice one i think very
smooth positional game
hey gary
okay i want to go d5 open up my position
here because h4 yeah that makes sense
now the time is ripe i think for that
then bishop g-force oh he goes h5 like
that
but if he takes he has to be very
careful about a g
and then the pressure on the knife
becomes
very significant
it goes h6
damn girl
really riley
goes d3 so now
let's weigh the pros and cons of taking
takes nah he takes the queen we want to
keep this pin so let's go back to g7
thank you gary within 18 months
it was queen d2
alright so potentially he wants queen f4
you can go d5 here we can go
if i go 96 he has some knight h2
nonsense
rookie 8 also makes sense
queen d7 maybe just solidify everything
kila gifting to metal eagle
damn girl
yeah he's tangled up i don't think that
creates too many threats we can go here
on queen f4 i probably can go just f5
he's thinking about queen f4 i can
guarantee you
doesn't really do much i think
ah
i'm trying to
work out bishop takes f3 so bishop f3
bishop f3 d5 knight f6 bishop f6 and
against rookie i can play 98 i think
this might win a piece
no we have to eliminate the defender of
the rook on e1 before we attack the
knight i think
it's the zen of this position
and f5 is even stronger than d5 which i
originally wanted
make you just
inclusive 10 months
i think this just wins
okay we continue
yeah
i shouldn't go e4 i should go see
something else
okay let's go d3
okay let's play like a philidor
structure a quiet positional
i don't mind that
all right so let's go b3 maybe bishop a3
maybe a4 bishop a3
b2 first a4 to grab some space
yeah donations uh through paypal are
obviously 100
to the streamer
all right so now we need to figure out
how to play here i think c3 is generally
considered the idea here
c5
shouldn't have done that because
i kind of forgot about this f5 idea
if you're retooling my position like
this makes sense getting the bishop to a
civilized square
i don't mind him taking on c4
i think then i can play bc
b1 thank you naka4 for the prime
okay now
who benefits in the event of a bishop
trade it's probably me because
my lights both of my bishops are bad
actually
actually kind of like my position
ones of this
well i'm going to try to make the bishop
better i mean right now it's staring at
the fun
he's biting on granite but not anymore
not anymore
now our bishop is good we've got other
problems to worry about this pawn is
weak this knight is very strong
so how do we want to do this king h2
maybe just get the king out of the
danger zone
maybe we can start yeah let's go k2 try
to solidify the position
gotta donate 10 bucks from justin
on anything thank you appreciate that
tip
i'm sure he will appreciate the free
pawn i just gave him
i think
a little bit worried about this move
i guess we'll cross that bridge when we
get there it takes wow
really riley
see
probably like the karpov move is a
rookie two here just to stop
i think he's winning
yeah i was worried about that move
okay i think he bought a bluff
no maybe here
thank you slushers
now i think the tides have turned
somewhat now i'm just winning yes this
queen is excluding
okay now it's plus two for a win so
maybe this is a good time to
abort okay i'm gonna give him another
game
make it even
he likes this
structure
yeah i think he probably was winning at
some point there
this is an old line which i'm playing
very incompetently
okay so let's go b5 let's try to
open some stuff up here before it's too
late
okay i thought that here i can get my
knight to d4 and then i take on b5
if chess was solved by machines would
humans still play that's a great
question and i think the answer to that
fabi originally made this point i think
the answer is yes
i i've thought about that as well i
heard some interview with fabio where he
made i think a very good point
that
even if chess is solved let's say 30
years down the line
nobody would be able to remember there
would be a psychological
disappointment i think in knowing the
proper result but at the same time i
think people would get over it i think
it's
the same thing
people must have
used to think that
when computers would become stronger
than humans people would stop playing
chess and they haven't
so i think the same kind of thing is
going to happen here
and chess has been solved partially with
seven pieces or fewer and that doesn't
stop anybody nobody knows nobody's
gotten better at endgames because table
bases have been developed
i mean
the development of table basis has had a
limited effect on people's end game
mastery i think
what does solve chess means it means
computer could basically process every
possible position in line and say who
should win with best play from both
sides
like if you go down the tree
what should be the appropriate result
it's kind of a complicated concept i
think
like does white always win does black
always win that's highly doubtful
okay that's a blunder
yeah i think there's some compelling i'm
not good at good on this math but i
think there's
a case to be made that it's not going to
be solved anytime soon given like the
computing power that we have right now
or lack thereof
i think i'm gonna sack the
exchange back and just play up a pawn
for
i do think computers make chess
unbalanced less interesting but
i also acknowledge that's not really the
popular opinion
i mean
less interesting is very subjective term
no i definitely do
no i don't remember that
ha
it's interesting because on in stanford
i got a lot of
i got this question from a lot of like
friends and people i knew who didn't
mean it like maliciously
but it seemed that a lot of people were
not able to process the fact that
computers are better than humans but we
we still play like
it's your own ass oh my god
terrible
terrible terrible terrible
seem to take care yeah
i think uh
there's a case to be made that given any
task x
um
you could design a computer that you
could design something that's better
than a human at that task
so that concept is far from
surprising
and yeah i mean
chess is just one of those tasks
i think
well
objective tasks let's limit that to
objective tasks
art is a subjective
let's limit that to tasks where the
judgment is at least somewhat objective
rather than subjective
now i'm not saying that computers are
better at everything i'm saying you
hypothetically you could imagine a
computer that's better than
a human at those objective tasks
and i'm not saying that they will be for
decades to come but rather that it's
metaphysically possible
but that's not stopping us or just from
being the best that we can be i think in
most areas
i'm sure there's a lot of math behind
this
yeah we can also smash the computer and
for now they can't smash us but maybe
that'll change as well
for now yeah that might change
at some point so enjoy enjoy the power
while we have it
okay this is completely unimpressive
this position
this is definitely the last game with
him
okay who's this guy read nova i think
that's a wonder
this is actually maybe worse for white
and that's the blender
yeah i think things like art probably
might even be optimizable in the long
run but
i think machinery is now used i think to
create art so it's is this night trapped
jesus
oh my god i think his knight is strength
again but the point is not that
currently computers are but i think
people some people are stumbling on that
notion
all right good games games
yeah exactly
queen b3 no i i just got lucky asl
in this particular game i mean i i was
an honest blunder
i don't know if he has a defense after
queen b3
that's ridiculous
this knight is just trapped i mean he's
got no
no squares
e5 i can take on e6
yeah
incredible
all right well we take those
i have time maybe for a couple more
let's see if i can get another opponent
four five six seven eight nine ten that
was adoption by the way for those
watching at home
not that it really matters
[Music]